- [Voiceover] Pegging:
an act of intercourse
where a woman inserts
a strap-on dildo
into the anus of
her male partner.
- Christina and Tom!
So why pegging?
- 12 years I've been
threatening him with pegging.
- But clearly you've
shown interest
in having your
behind stimulated.
You want a finger.
- I've wanted, yes, a finger.
- Wait, have you
given the finger?
- [Both] No!
- She won't even do that.
- No, but let me tell you--
- But she's gonna
shove a dildo in me.
- My boyfriend's into
stuff back there,
he just won't let
himself admit it.
- That's awesome.
- One of the common fears
about pegging is poop.
- I am afraid that it's
just, I'm gonna get showered
in shit, but that's kind
of the price I'm gonna pay
to give him a good pegging.
- Another fear is being
seen as, you know, gay.
Is that a fear of yours?
- No.
I mean, if somebody
accuses me of being gay,
then I'll just come all
over their face, I guess.
- He's been crushing my
puss, devastating it,
for years and years.
I know he's straight.
- Yeah, it's not gay because the
dildo is attached to a woman.
- I'm just thrilled to
finally massacre his asshole.
I'm really excited.
- Also pain, pain
is a big concern.
- I'd say pain's the
number one concern.
- Because she's
using words like--
- Devastate, destroy, yes, yes.
- Okay, butt class is starting.
- All right.
- Hello everybody.
- Hi!
- Welcome to Ruby
Ryder's Pegging 101
and congratulations
for being here.
The men, why would
you want to do this?
Pleasure, flat out pleasure.
The prostate gland is like the
magic button for guys, okay?
- You wanna write that down?
- Yes.
- And there's an equal
amount of potential pleasure
with the prostate just like
there is with the G-spot.
So the rules are not
too fast, not too big.
- How big can I go?
- You start small in general.
- Can you show me what
that would look like?
- Yeah.
Right here.
- Whoa, whoa.
That's introductory level?
- Yes it is.
- You can handle that.
- I think I was looking at your
stick of Chapstick over there.
- This is actually a vibe.
- Okay, that's what I want.
- If you are going
to get something
that's a size of your
finger, use your finger.
- Oh right.
- You know?
This goes in here.
For the woman.
- [Tom] Good lord.
- [Christina] Oh that's cool.
- Give you ladies
some incentive.
- Right ladies?
- Jesus.
- So you put it on like this.
I'm liking it already!
It already feels a
part of who I am.
- Nicki, this looks good on you.
- Women are afraid
of what they're
gonna look like
wearing a strap-on.
- Is this what
it's like for you?
- No, that's not what
it's like for me.
- So when you pee,
you hold it down?
Oh yeah, I forgot that part!
- It's been a long day.
(sighs)
- I wish I had balls on this.
- They have ones with balls.
- Do the balls smell?
- No.
- Like a real, I would
want them to just
smell like a man's balls.
- So this is a dual density one.
It's a softer outer
core, harder inner one.
- Whoa.
- Okay, I thought
a good way to like
test out if we
are good thrusters
is with some clay
asses that I had made.
- Wow.
- [Nicki] Let's just
go to town on them.
- They're clay assholes.
I don't get any lube, seriously?
- Yep, okay, I'm entering.
- You're just a
natural, look at you.
- No I'm not, oh,
it's going in baby!
- [Christina] This
is what you do?
- Yeah.
- Oh no, it's prolapsing.
Is this gonna happen?
- Whoa.
- This is for not getting me
flowers on Valentine's Day!
This is for taking me
to Home Depot instead!
- I feel like Nicki's
got a lot of rage.
- Oh my god, I broke it!
- [Tom] Jesus.
- Oh my god, oh my god!
Wow.
- I broke my dick!
- I was very loving.
- Yes!
It was nice knowing that this
couldn't break up with me.
- I'm really proud
of how nice you
were to the clay butthole.
- Thanks, sweetie.
- But I still think
we go finger first.
- Got it.
All right, I love you.
- I love you.
- I'm tired.